i was completely unaware of how
entertaining the johnny depp amber heard
trial is i wish i had watched the first
season you know the trial over in london
i have not
been watching it but i do have a we can
do this together i can give you some of
the highlights so you and i can get up
to date on this thing so johnny depp
testified in court for two days last
week tons of accusations but here's the
one the key issue involves who
[ __ ] in the bed in 2016.
she's claiming it was the couple's dogs
but johnny claims amber pooped in the
bed and there's nothing funnier than
this she brought up the situation of the
her
fecal matter on the bed
and
i
uh
and she just tried to blame it on the
dogs
why didn't you think it could have been
the dogs
the dogs were
their teacup yorkies they weigh about
four pounds each
and that was not
none of that did not come from a dog
your honor the [ __ ] was the size of the
dog
your honor have you ever taken a [ __ ] as
big as you are
[Laughter]
i don't think so
i rest my case
all i kept thinking was lizzy i mean
lucy and desi never thought of these
scenarios in the whole of the i love
lucy's show
never [ __ ] in the bed and if you notice
he takes huge dramatic pauses yes
especially when he's about to mention
dog poop like it's just too
too much i don't want to even say it yet
yeah here's some clips of johnny depp
describing human fecal matter
there's a photograph of the bed
our
bed um
and on
my side of the bed
um
was human fecal matter
[Music]
your honor it was
human feces
if i was auditioning for saturday night
live this would be my monologue for lord
michael yes
there was corn
great chunks of it your honor
it smelled like death
lifeless
materials
[Laughter]
the lawyers must have lectured johnny
depp on how to refer to feces because he
called it dropping a grumpy what
i thought that some
human being had actually
dropped a
grumpy
[Music]
pardon the term
on to the bed how dare you you can't say
dropping a grumpy that's not even a term
how dare you listen johnny i went to
harvard law and one of the things i know
is if you say [ __ ] in court you're
you're done you gotta say drop a grumpy
it's over johnny
your honor they were yucking it up they
were laughing
because stop
and excuse my language
she had squeezed the cheese
if you know what i mean in my bed
iran forgive me but she had produced a
rectal pie
and johnny gets all embarrassed you like
you know he's acting takes a long pause
you're on yeah i i don't usually use
this word
i want you to please excuse this but
she pushed manure out of her turd cutter
she squeezed out a deuce
she
she took the browns to the super bowl